encouragement
if these measures are applied to collect
tariffs from mexico
as I understand it
and they would start
and take place
on monday
it is still friday
and there is dialogue
and an agreement can be reached i am
optimistic that an agreement
will be reached i go to
jesus so that here today  make sure
you know that the national guard is being created
and it will have a
presence throughout the country and of course it will have a
presence on the southern border and on the
northern border and in all of mexico there are
coordinations throughout the country so yesterday that
Marcelo announced that the National Guard will act
on the southern border as it
is part of a security program
and according to the constitution and the
laws,
the National Guard can help
support tasks for migratory functions
protection of facilities already there  a
legal framework that allows it but it is a
national plan
I own my silence
but of course helping the
city to this state we need to
maintain a very good  relationship when the
usa
I want to continue being friends with
the president of donald trump